bref ce matin là j'ai décidé qu'il
fallait absolument que je fasse mon set
montage de rêve je me suis fait un café
j'ai regardé mon café j'ai voulu filmer
mon café et je me suis dit que ça
faisait un petit peu trop peter makina
alors j'ai décidé qu'il valait mieux
plagie bref chercher sur l'internet
j'ai rien trouvé j'ai joué à caen dick
roche pendant une heure et je me suis
rendu compte que j'avais perdu une heure
je me suis dit qu'il me restait qu'une
seule solution c'était appelé les potes
et leur demander leur avis j'ai appelé
julien fabre au rsa lüscher et s
françois savalas far west aurait un truc
pour faire un set up de rêve de fou pour
le montage la tête de rêve
c'est avant de parler de cette heure je
pense qu'il faut l'accessoire ultime que
tous nos tubes heures se doit d'avoir
j'avais toujours pas de solution
j'ai appelé didier de match au razer
jean-françois j'espère tu as encore tu
es dehors parce qu'apple s'est pas donné
amplement
j'avais toujours pas de solution j'ai
appelé olivier schmitt françois installe
davinci résolve arrête de faire ton
mariole avec un essai une fois de
professionnaliser un petit peu et de
voir ce que c'est que la vraie vidéo
j'avais toujours pas de solution j'ai
appelé un disque je me suis dit que le
mans était mort et j'avais toujours pas
de solution bref j'ai monté mon set up
de rêve
[Musique]
il salua tous les gens derrière l'écran
c'est françois pour la chaîne explique
mme encore je suis ravie comme à chaque
fois de vous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle vidéo aujourd'hui on va parler
d'une question que vous me posez
régulièrement quel est mon setup de
montage quel matériel j'utilise pour
monter mes vidéos et puis plus largement
quelles sont les points importants quand
on veut s'équiper en matériel de montage
alors quand il ya pas mal de choses me
suis dit que j'allais faire une grosse
vidéo assez complète avec tout le matos
et vous expliquer comment j'ai fait ce
fameux c'est un de mes rêves qui envoie
du très très très très lourd alors
accrochez-vous on y va c'est parti et
puis comme j'ai opté pour un set
modulaire à rester bien jusqu'à la fin
de la vidéo parce que tous les éléments
une marche un petit peu ont servi alors
comme je fais du montage tous les jours
de manière professionnelle bas il
fallait une bestiole qui envoie du lourd
quand il fallait un truc je pouvais pas
aller prendre un mac d'entrée de gamme
et vie parce que vu que je monte sur
final cut c'est un mac obligatoire ou
alors un hackintosh mais le hackintosh
j'étais pas prêt psychologiquement alors
j'ai commencé à lorgner du côté de l'ail
mac pro et là c'est financièrement que
j'étais pas prêt psychologiquement parce
que forcément pour avoir des config qui
sont idéales pour le montage on arrive
sur des prix qui sont astronomiques sur
les mac
donc j'ai essayé de trouver une solution
un petit peu alternative le truc c'est
que j'avais déjà pas mal d'éléments
notamment le clavier la souris j'avais
un moniteur aussi donc je n'avais pas
forcément besoin d'acheter un imac ou un
imac trop et c'est pourquoi mon choix
s'est porté sur le nouveau mac mini
celui de 2018 et il est petit mais
costaud s'agit d'un mac mini core i7 à
3,2 gigahertz et un hexacoeurs ça veut
dire qu'il a six coeurs et c'est une
bombe en calcul de processeurs les
belges démontré qu'il était plus
puissant en termes de processeurs que
les imac d'ancienne génération les plus
poussées donc ça fait une base identique
est hyper solide et ce qui est bien sûr
ce modèle c'est que la ram peut être up
grade et lé pas soudé donc j'ai pris la
version 8 giga j'ai acheté 32 gigas de
ram de mon côté je les ai fait monter
dans un centre agréé parce que sinon tu
perds ta garantie et ça m'a coûté
beaucoup moins cher que de faire leur
grade sur le site d'apple ou aulas c'est
tout simplement du vol en 700 euros les
32 gigas de ram
ah et puis le ssd à l'intérieur en
interne du mac mini j'ai pris la version
512 giga et en termes de performances si
juste de la formule en quoi le truc va à
une vitesse
hallucinante donc on a une très bonne
base un très bon ordinateur donc voilà
c'est bon et non ça serait trop simple
et ouais parce que ce mac mini là quand
même un énorme défaut c'est sa carte
graphique a plutôt sa puce graphique qui
est totalement anémiques par rapport aux
capacités du processeur et là pour le
coup c'est vraiment pas quelque chose
qui envoie du lourd et encore moins pour
du montage vidéo pour vous donner un
exemple j'ai ouvert un projet motion
avec pas mal d'animations un truc un
petit peu complexe mais qui faisait
quinze secondes le temps de rendu
annoncé c'était 45 minutes du truc
énorme et donc en termes de performances
graphiques c'est même pas la peine d'y
penser mais ça je l'avais anticipé ça
nous amène au deuxième élément de ce set
up
auparavant j'avais déjà investi dans ce
qu'on appelle un oui j'ai pu ainsi j'ai
pu tout simplement c'est un boîtier dans
lequel on va pouvoir mettre une carte
graphique de deux tours fixe et qui va
venir se brancher en thunderbolt 3 sur
le mac mini sound un bol 3 en termes de
débit ça très défouraille et ça permet
donc d'avoir une vraie carte graphique
sur ce mac mini cannes graphique de son
choix dans la mesure où elles sont
compatibles avec mac os
hélas là j'ai pas lésiné là j'ai pris la
vega 64 qui est la carte graphique
équipe les imac trop haut de gamme donc
vraiment le le top du top
et là ça a changé totalement la donne le
fameux fichier motion qui était censé
s'exporter en 45 minutes
il s'est exporté 1 25 secondes voilà
c'est suivent juste pour vous donner un
ordre d'idée pure tuerie est clairement
je pense que ce mac mini à moins qu'on
fasse de la bureautique mais dans ce cas
là on n'aurait pas besoin de l'exacte
heures il est prévu pour avoir un gpu au
cul ce que finalement il y aurait aucun
sens à avoir un ordinateur qui a un
processeur aussi puissant ssd aussi
rapide et autant de ram 6 niveaux
graphiques ça fait rien du tout quoi si
s'il est capable de rien bon j'exagère
un peu il n'est pas capable de rien mais
pour du montage c'est juste pas possible
et avec cet ajout du gpu bailly prend je
vais oser le dire une dimension
totalement professionnel
alors il faut savoir quand même que les
débits qu'on va avoir avec une carte
graphique même la même en sounder bolt
et en interne dans un ordinateur seront
pas les mêmes la i mac pro avec sa vague
à 64 il a quand même des performances
plus élevées que mon mac mini avec son
mii gpu même si c'est la même carte
branché en thunderbolt et pour ce que je
fais moi c'est les retraités de la 4k du
multicam en 4k des effets de la colo
même des plugins un petit peu gourmand
franchement ça passe comme une
la poste comme papa dans maman oui j'ai
osé la ressortir je sais qu'elle est
dégueulasse cette vanne
voilà vous imaginez vos parents
maintenant et apparemment c'est surtout
sur des fichiers comme le format raw des
caméras red ou là vraiment là et macpro
explose le mac mini et son gpu mais
c'est pas du tout le matériel que
j'utilisais donc pour l'instant il n'y a
aucun souci a pas besoin d'avoir une
machine plus puissante la vraiment j'ai
un truc top moumoute ce qui nous amène
au troisième élément puisque bas âge et
ma tour complète je ne leur dirai carte
graphique le clavier la souris mais le
moniteur ça reste quelque chose aussi
dit pères important surtout quand on
travaille sur l'image et là j'ai eu
l'agréable surprise d'avoir un coup de
fil de benq qui m'a envoyé leur écran
spécial post-production pour je puisse
pas le tester sur mon set up et il
s'agit donc du modèle pv 270 de chez
benq alors je vous ai dit juste avant
que j'avais un moniteur déjà j'avais un
moniteur lambda ou un truc pas folichon
que j'avais pas payer très cher il avait
l'avantagé d'être en scène d'un bol 3
mais sa charge est pas complètement
macbook 15 pouces donc finalement
j'utilisais en hdmi avec le gpu donc y
avait pas un grand intérêt
là le gros intérêt que j'ai vu avec ce
benq c'est la fidélité de l'image par
rapport à ce que j'ai sur le moniteur
parce que sur mon ancien moniteur qui
était pas prévu pour ben j'avais
toujours la désagréable surprise quand
je regardais mes vidéos une fois
exporter sur mon téléphone sur une télé
sur une tablette d'avoir des changements
assez important en termes de couleurs
termes d'exposition même des fois je
filmais je les tiens l'exposition est
super très bien et je regardais sur mon
moniteur ça marche est nickel et quand
je passais sur mon téléphone bas c'était
sous-exposés c'était surexposer les
couleurs étaient pas les mêmes
enfin c'était c'était hyper chiant et
j'ai dû refaire plein de fois des vidéos
à l'aveuglé en regardant le rendu que
j'avais sur mon téléphone en me disant
attendre là c'est trop saturé je vais
baisser la saturation ça fait hyper
désaturer sur mon écran mais sur mon
iphone ça rend bien
donc c'était une sacrée perte de temps
au final et puis il y avait toujours ce
va et vient qui était assez pénible là
le moniteur il est déjà réglé de base
mais on peut rentrer dans les réglages
assez faire dire j'ai bossé sur les cas
de l'inde qui a sorti ou qui va sortir
une vidéo sur cet écran là qui va être
bien pousser donc allé la voir vachement
bien et donc clairement un gain de temps
sur l'export sur la vérification des
couleurs je sais que tout est unique et
il ya même un petit plus bien sympa sur
la tranche du moniteur on retrouve un
port sd et deux ports usb qui sont hyper
pratique pour décharger les cartes sd
pour brancher une clé usb et surtout que
bas sur le mac mini comme sur plat
plupart des mac maintenant il ya plus de
port sd pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi vous
enlevez les ports sd pourquoi vous
voulez nous vendre des adaptateurs pour
mettre nos cartes sd quand vous savez
qu'on et photographes ou vidéastes
pourquoi un apple donc au quotidien
c'est un petit truc qui paye pas de mine
mais c'est hyper pratique et une petite
fonctionnalité doc qui est vraiment
sympa en plus sur cet écran on sent que
ça a été pensé pour les vidéastes
vraiment mais c'est pas fini
et encore une dernière chose que je
voulais pour ce set up pour que vraiment
ça soit mon set up de rêve et ça c'était
le stockage
donc je vous disais j'ai pris un mac
mini 512 giga en disque dur interne ce
qui est largement suffisante pour
stocker tous les programmes des photos
plein de choses enfin tout ce dont j'ai
deux joints au quotidien même largement
plus du coup j'ai pas à m'en faire pour
le stockage interne de la machine
par contre je travaille avec des
fichiers qui sont très très lourd un là
pour vous donner une idée une vidéo
comme celle ci que je suis en train de
tourner et qui est une petite vidéo avec
très peu de fichiers il y en a pour 20
ou 30 giga facile et donc il faut de la
place pour mettre tout ça et avant
j'utilisais bas tout ça est plein de
petits disques durs à droite à gauche
alors je mettais des étiquettes dessus
pour me repérer mais enfin les
transvaser fallait galères cendres et là
encore il ya une gentille marque qui m'a
proposé de m'envoyer un truc dont je
rêvais depuis un moment c'est un système
en raid
en l'occurrence le lacie to big doc qui
est un système qu'on peut mettre un
un raid 0 raid 1 on a deux disques durs
ici de d'iter à chacun qui se copient
l'un l'autre en permanence donc s'il en
est un qui claque on l'enlève en en mai
un autre sastre copie tout va bien et en
va de zéro on cumule les deux fois
d'itéra donc 20 terra plus des
performances qui vont être augmentés
mais on n'a pas la sécurité de la copie
de la redondance sur chaque disque est
donc moi je l'aimé en raid 1 pour
stocker tous les fichiers de base quand
je vis de ma carte sd je la vide sur ce
disque dur et à côté de ça je monte sur
un ssd externes petit samsung de 1 tera
dans un boîtier oki qui marche très bien
et qui est pas cher et en usb sait et on
fera une vidéo dédiée spécifique au
stockage à la sauvegarde et à
l'archivage
mais ça serait trop long d'en rajouter
dans cette vidéo donc on fera une
vraiment spécifique à ça du coup cela si
tu oublies que je me rêvais depuis un
moment parce que déjà il ya une sécurité
supplémentaire comme on a les deux
disques qui se copient en permanence on
a plus de sécurité même s'il existe des
systèmes à 4 ou 5 b avec encore plus de
sécurité pour moi ça suffit amplement
c'est pas la sécurité absolue il peut
toujours se passer quelque chose de
pâques où l'on peut toujours perdre ses
données mais ça rajoute quand même plus
de sécurité pour les données parce que
je me vois mal après un shooting de
mariage dire aux gens et je suis désolé
chez un disque mon disque dur qu'elle a
claqué j'ai perdu toutes les images de
votre film de mariage vous voulez pas
qu'on leur fasse pour voir non ça ça ça
passe pas donc là j'ai une sécurité
supplémentaire
alors maintenant qu'on a fait le tour
vous allez me dire mais pourquoi tu as
acheté tous ces trucs là alors qu'en
fait au final ben tu te retrouves si on
calcule sur le prix d'un très bon imac
pas un imac promet d'un très bon imac
haut de gamme
pourquoi je suis parti sur une config où
il ya tous ces éléments va déjà dans un
premier temps la vision à long terme
un imac pour leur grade et c'est très
compliqué certains on peut quand même
rajouter de la ram d'autres s'est soudé
mes cartes graphiques enfin tout c'est
un tout-en-un si on veut leur grade et
on le vend on en achète un autre et
c'est pas forcément ce que j'ai envie de
faire moi j'ai envie d'avoir une machine
qui pourra évoluer dans le temps là avec
le yi gpu par exemple je peux changer la
carte graphique si le mac mini un jour
devient un petit peu poussif
bien que là il a encore deux
de beaux jours devant lui je changerais
juste le mac mini qui ne coûtera pas un
bras si je veux changer le moniteur je
peux changer le moniteur bref je peux
tout changé séparément et je peux tout
autre gradé en fonction de mes besoins
et l'autre point qui m'a poussé à
choisir cette config là c'est que
j'avais déjà pas mal n'existant le
moniteur le clavier la souris j'avais
déjà le gpu donc en gros j'ai juste
acheté le mac mini
donc au final ça aurait été dommage
d'acheter un mac pour me retrouver avec
un clavier une souris en double à
revendre autre chose comme ça un
moniteur qui m'ont servi à rien et j gpu
qui aurait pas forcément été plus
puissant que le gpu interne de l'imac
surtout lime axa aurait fait une grosse
dépense quand même donc au final je suis
ravie vraiment ravi de ce set up c'est
vraiment celui là que je voulais c'est
vraiment comme ça que je le voulais il
est hyper puissant il est hyper rapide
pour ce que je fais au quotidien ça va
vite et vraiment c'est du bonheur
d'éditer de la 4k sans avoir à faire des
proxys même en multicam c'est du bonheur
de pas se dire tiens je mettais le
plugin met alors à temps et va falloir
que je fasse gaffe parce que je vais
voir la petite roue apple qui va me dire
ah j'ai du mal j'en chie tubes en
demande trop d'un et j'irai même plus
loin il y avait des tâches qui mettait
mon macbook pro 15 pouces un petit peu à
genoux un la lui ils branchent pas mais
vraiment pas j'ai eu aucun souci avec
quels que soient les tâches que je lui
ai demandé quelle que soit la puissance
dont j'avais besoin il a toujours
répondu présent et vraiment je pense que
je vais garder cette ope un bon moment
et puis comme je vous disais ainsi il ya
des choses qui évoluent la carte
graphique ou des choses comme ça je
craindrais au fur et à mesure il ça ne
coûtera pas un bras et voilà les amis
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui j'espère que
cette vidéo vous aura plu si c'est le
cas n'hésitez pas à faire comme
d'habitude à mettre le traditionnel coup
de blaster sur le pouce en l'air qui
situe juste en dessous de cette vidéo
merci à tous les guest en début de vidéo
vraiment c'était un grand kiff de faire
cette intro je vous fait des bises les
copains c'était hyper sympa merci à benq
merci à la si je vous mets tous les
liens de ce long temps apparaît dans
cette vidéo dans la description si vous
voulez voir les specs ce vraiment
technique est vraiment détaillé
et puis moi je vous dis rester curieux
au coeur sur vous et à très bientôt pour
une prochaine vidéo